I heard an interview from Michael Apted
who's the director of many films and he
was the originator of the up series it's
the British documentary about the
various schoolchildren who then grown up
and they've followed their lives and 56
years of filmmaking on mom I don't know
if it's 56 years but it's it's several
years several generations several
decades of their life he talked about
how he noticed that the people that
devoted their lives to family seemed to
be very happy and content with who they
were where is the ones that were driven
more by their careers and he admits to
being one of them sometimes missed out
on certain joys and I'm sort of
paraphrasing what he said going back to
being self-aware you were talking about
maybe being a people person versus not
being a people person how important do
you think it is for someone to be
self-aware in order to propel them to a
next level because if you're not it
seems like you would just stay stuck
what a question this is something I've
learned in maybe the last year a couple
of years I'm a little nervous you've
asked this question but I will be honest
I remember somebody a very like a mentor
of mine many years ago said that because
I've had a variety of careers and he he
said like I think you could you could do
any career but I'm not sure how far you
could get in it and I remember thinking
when he said that you really angry with
him and I didn't say anything I just but
what this was a few years ago and I
think he was referring to my particular
stage of personal development then and
it was basically being able to achieve
things as an artist he's not just about
how talented I am it may be it is for
others but for me it's not just about
how talented I am it's about knowing
being aware of my flaws being aware of
how I react to people and how people
react to how I am and trying to
compensate for that trying to make
allowances for that so for example and
and I I believe that the limits in the
career I'm at now I'm not convinced are
going to be set by my talent I think
they'll be set by my character and how
well I'm able to deal with things like
as we've talked about collaborating with
others things like how I behave after
I've had some publicity how I
collaborate might with the same people
after I've had some success do i how do
I does that change the way I am with
them as a person so I'm I'm I've
realised in the last couple years that's
going to be your the last year that
would be the limit you know it'll be my
emotional abilities
I believe rather than my technical or
talent abilities that will limit me so
I'm constantly trying to develop
personally to deal with that and I some
of the things I'm aware of when I get
caught up in the hurly-burly of a
project publicity I can become quite as
quite a lating I find it's quite
exciting when you see stuff and you get
people calling from papers or the TV or
whatever and you have a run of this and
I can get caught up in it basically and
how so well I look at if I look at my
heroes that I I read about or see on TV
or whatever okay and I'm impressed by
them alright
then I get noticed a little bit in the
press and on TV and I think there's a
part of my brain that says oh I'm a
little bit like those people that I'm
impressed by maybe I'm impressive
alright and I start to become any sort
of character flora might I've become
overly impressed by myself now that can
impact how I am with the people that I
depend on in two ways first of all I
depend on them because without them
there's no project without them there's
no audience without them there's no
infrastructure
for me to work with him the other reason
I'm dependent is if it's all about the
project yet I understand this idea that
you can get obsessed with business with
the art and you lose out on a personal
level but if that goes too far what's
the point of the art if I can't share
that with someone apart from people
reading a newspaper it for a very short
period of time knowing that there's a
bunch of people out there reading about
what you're doing and being impressed by
it or seeing what you're doing and being
impressed for a very short period of
time that can substitute for general
genuine human contact but in the end
what really matters is being able to
talk to somebody you care about or
you're close to really being able to
share it with someone physically who's
there
and so these relationships need to be
maintained both to just what's the point
of achieving what you achieve unless you
can share it with the people that you
work with around you and Robin
you know then thinking always getting
too big for his boots now has been on
television or something and also these
people you've got to work with them
professionally in the future so that I
think has been the most important thing
that I've learned and I will so some of
the things I'll do I will overcompensate
in my mind I will think I'm probably
being too pushy or too arrogant here
I'll rather be what I'd rather rather be
less arrogant what am I trying to say
I'd rather not be arrogant enough will
not be pushy enough just to take to
compensate what I know is my tendency
for when a project is starting to get
popular and interesting my tendency to
inflate my own sense of importance and
my own sense of what's right and so
forth so that that's something I've
learned recently the term but the good
news is this I the fact I've said this
to you I wouldn't say this to you if I
didn't have a handle on this I wouldn't
say this to you if it was a floor I was
aware of that I hadn't developed tools
for dealing with it and it's um
I mean there's that this is just the one
I've been dude you know I've had to deal
with multiple ones before and things
like avoiding problems is a big one and
I think everyone does it avoiding
conflict these are all I hate conflict I
will a let a project run late or or
become more risky because I just don't
want to have the conflict of saying to
someone I'm overly nervous of
jeopardizing professional relationships
so I don't like to say to someone and
this is probably related to the conflict
thing I don't like to say to someone
like no I don't want to do this or no
we've got to do it this way because I'm
overly nervous that will damage the
professional relationship this game
party self confessional but these are
all I think the good news is if this
sounds like I'm being very negative on
myself the fact I'm able to say it shows
that I've got a better chance of
developing this career which is the
career that's been closest to my heart
of all the ones that I've done and tried
over the years I've got a better chance
of actually moving this one forward
because in the end art for me maybe it's
different for others but for me the
meaning of art lies not just in the art
by didn't people and if I'm isolating
myself from people if I'm unable to
function within a team-based environment
if I'm going off into the yeah I think
that that's that sums it up you know
what is there what's the point
you